[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
comenzamos
en la última década el número de
brasileños que se han visto obligados a
vivir en la calle ha crecido un 139 por
ciento en 2012 el país contabilizaba 92
mil 550 personas sin techo para 2020 ya
eran 222 mil con 12 millones de
habitantes sao paulo es la ciudad con un
número récord de personas sin hogar
según una ong local los ciudadanos en
situación de calle son al menos 66 mil
el doble de la estimación realizada por
las autoridades los sintechos son un
fenómeno común también en otras urbes
como río de janeiro donde hay
aglomeraciones indigentes incluso en las
calles más lujosas estamos hoy en
directo con nuestra corresponsal vale ya
está con que realizó este reportaje
junto a guillermo acevedo ya piragine
juan hola valeria comienzo preguntándole
los últimos datos revelan que en brasil
33 millones de brasileños están pasando
hambre el último dato salió en 2020 y
hablaba de 19 millones de personas que
no conseguían alimentarse de la forma
correcta esto se nota en las calles del
país
se nota mucho en las plazas y calles
donde hemos grabado en sant paro en río
de janeiro donde se distribuye a comida
gratis no había solo sin techo también
personas que con la crisis económica
está la inflación se ven obligadas a
elegir entre pagar el alquiler comprar
una bombona de gas o comprar alimentos
entonces muchas personas aprovechan esa
distribución y se bajan a la calle a
comer junto a los indigentes brasil en
2014 durante el gobierno de dilma
rousseff consiguió salir del mapa del
hambre de la fao la organización de las
naciones unidas para la alimentación y
la agricultura sin embargo en el primer
año del gobierno de brasil de jair
bolsonaro volvió a este mapa del hambre
es la primera vez en la historia que un
país sale y entra de este mapa y es un
retroceso de más de 30 años porque hoy
los niveles de hambre en brasil son los
mismos que los años 90 y valeria la
situación de los sintechos en sao paulo
es cada vez más complicada el gobierno
local está haciendo algo para mejorar
las condiciones de estos ciudadanos
la verdad que no parece que haga mucho
las personas que están haciendo cosas
para esas personas como distribuirá agua
comida y mantas son las iglesias tanto
las católicas como las evangélicas las
ongs y voluntarios como valeria una de
las protagonistas de nuestro reportaje
además el gobierno local se dedica de
los últimos meses a desmantelar la cara
colonia en lugar de consumo de crack que
en el centro de san pablo- llegaba a
reunir a 25 mil personas por día está
generado una atención muy grande las
calles del centro porque los
narcotraficantes controlan ya muchos
barrios y venden crack a la luz del sol
y personas que se encuentran en la calle
por haber perdido el trabajo y tener a
los parientes lejos en ciudades de otros
estados se ven obligadas a convivir con
drogodependientes la situación es tensa
en varias ocasiones nos han amenazados o
invitado cordialmente a irnos de la
región para evitar problemas
gracias valeria sakona por acompañarnos
ahora veamos la historia
[Música]
san paolo la urbe más poblada de brasil
es hoy la capital de los sintecho unos
66.000 indigentes mal viven en las
calles de la ciudad más rica del país
según varias ongs este dato duplica las
cifras oficiales y revela un aumento de
casi tres veces desde el último censo
oficial realizado hace dos años antes de
la pandemia
[Música]
esta iglesia es un remanso de paz donde
esas personas se encuentran comida y
afecto
desde las 7 de la mañana la actividad es
frenética
todos los días el padre julio lancelot y
sirve el desayuno a más de 600 personas
sin hogar
en moca un tradicional barrio de san
paolo este sacerdote es muy popular
en los últimos dos años la cantidad de
personas que frecuentan este comedor
social se ha disparado pasando de 200 a
600 por día con picos de 2000
es la crisis que estamos viviendo
agravada por la pandemia
número sin techo aumenta en sao paulo
por encima del crecimiento demográfico
de la ciudad eso es espantoso
el desempleo figura entre las razones
principales en brasil hay 11,3 millones
de parados es casi el mismo número de
habitantes que tiene bolivia este
vigilante perdió el trabajo y el hogar
hace tres años
es la primera vez nunca pasé por esta
situación en la calle
mi objetivo es encontrar un empleo pero
de momento no lo estoy consiguiendo
algunas personas sin hogar ayudan al
padre julio como voluntarios diego es un
estudiante universitario que quiere ser
enfermero para ayudar a personas que
como él no tienen casa
las personas no me aceptan tan
fácilmente por no tener un lugar donde
vivir
algunos me discriminan en la facultad
dicen yo estudié toda la vida mi padre
trabajó en un banco es empresario y no
tengo por qué lidiar con personas así
este joven cuenta que unos cabezas
rapadas le intentaron quemar vivo
mientras dormía en una calzada
y alguien necesita una manta en el
último año padre julio ha lanzado una
campaña contra la prof obvia la fobia a
los pobres es un neologismo acuñado por
la filósofa española adela cortina y
popularizado en brasil por este cura
desde sus redes sociales denuncia los
ataques contra los sin techo como los
bloques de cemento y los cristales rotos
colocados para ahuyentarlos las personas
y están percibiendo aporofobia en sí
mismas las personas hoy están
percibiendo la aporofobia dentro de
decir que dentro de la ciudad y eso
ayuda mucho a encontrar instrumentos
para superarla hoy en el congreso
nacional se está tramitando una ley
contra las intervenciones hostiles y
también en la asamblea legislativa de
sao paulo
en san paolo el 1 por ciento de los
dueños de inmuebles concentra en sus
manos el
45% del valor inmobiliario los
trabajadores de baja renta no pueden
pagar un alquiler
[Música]
i
algunos consiguen escapar de la
precariedad ocupando edificios públicos
abandonados yo marina coordina un
movimiento que ofrece cobijo a personas
desamparadas que buscan una alternativa
a la calle
o la duda hola chicos
buenos días este mueble ocupado en
noviembre de 2021 funcionaba con un
asilo para ancianos hoy abriga a 62
familias y es administrado por mujeres
aquí es donde mi madre duerme con mi
hermana en el otro colchón duerme mi
hermano la okupación intenta paliar el
problema estructural de la falta de
vivienda san paolo tiene un déficit de
323 mil pisos
paradójicamente hay 290 mil edificios
vacíos en este contexto ocupar se
convierte en un acto político cuando se
comprende es abandonado ya denuncia
cuando ocupamos un edificio abandonado
como este es una denuncia para decir que
estos edificios no tienen una función
social de la propiedad podría ser
reformado y asignado a trabajadores de
renta baja las autoridades nunca hacen
eso duda cuenta que la policía intentó
impedir la ocupación de este edificio y
que los vecinos del barrio apoyaron la
operación
no estamos aquí porque nos parezca
bonito estamos aquí por necesidad un
alquiler hoy cuesta 240 dólares es casi
lo que yo gano no puedo pagarlo somos mi
marido mi hijo y yo mi marido ahora está
desempleado dígame cómo en medio de una
pandemia vamos a sobrevivir
en otro barrio de san paolo la mano
invisible de la solidaridad se
concretiza a través del esfuerzo de
activistas voluntarios javi organiza
estas cosas mientras yo cojo estas
bolsas varias veces por semana llevan
agua y mantas a los sin techo de la
plaza princesa isabel desde marzo se han
visto obligados a compartir su espacio
con los toxicómanos de la antigua crack
hollande ya
[Música]
estamos yendo a la nueva colonia porque
la vieja fue desalojada el 19 de marzo
más o menos 6.000 personas invadieron
una plaza de esta mayor de un campo de
fútbol
donde ya vivían unas 380 personas
la caracola nya surgió hace más de 30
años en el centro y llegó a concentrar a
25 mil personas por día
activistas como valeria denuncian que el
gobierno de san paulo no tiene voluntad
de solucionar este problema y se limita
a cambiar la cara hollandia del lugar
para revalorizar algunas calles del
centro
comenzaron unas obras de revitalización
de la vieja caracol andia y se agregaron
a las personas en esta plaza al final de
cuentas quedaron solo los toxicómanos y
las personas que venden piedras de crack
y otras drogas
con la llegada del otoño tropical el
frío aprieta y las donaciones son muy
esperadas
mañana volvemos para traer más mantas el
ambiente no es propicio para entrevistas
horas antes de nuestra llegada la
policía ha realizado una operación
contra el narcotráfico
los comerciantes de la plaza tienen
miedo de hablar y algunos usuarios de
crack nos invitan a salir del lugar
lugares la policía está en todas partes
como pueden ver pero no consigue acabar
con eso
son muy fuertes no consiguen
dispersarlos y arrestarlos hay intereses
políticos en todo esto pocos días
después la policía desmanteló también
este campamento un hombre murió durante
la operación
desde entonces los usuarios de crack
deambulan por el centro de san paolo en
busca de una nueva morada
río de janeiro es la postal de brasil
cada año cerca de un millón de turistas
visitan la ciudad maravillosa
copacabana el barrio más cosmopolita
también atrae a muchos mendigos que ven
en el alto poder adquisitivo de sus
habitantes una fuente de sustento
eso es por la trama de vez en cuando un
grupo de vecinos sale al malecón para
exigir más acción a las autoridades
después
el movimiento copacabana pide socorro
representa una parte de los brasileños
que en 2018 eligieron a jair bolsonaro
que en este barrio cosechó el 62 por
ciento de los votos
yo apoyo bolsonaro nunca seré del
partido de los trabajadores yo no estoy
satisfecha con nuestro gobernador y con
el alcalde con aquellos que gobiernan el
río de janeiro nuestra ciudad está
abandonado
[Música]
ellos nos agreden cuando vamos al banco
azúcar dinero no tenemos la culpa de
todo esto trabajamos fuimos educadas
quisimos optar por una vida mejor
para eduardo es uno de los organizadores
de la manifestación
este pescador nació en copacabana usa
las redes sociales para sensibilizar a
los vecinos del barrio sobre el
incremento de los usuarios de crack que
llegaron a instalarse en esta colonia
tenemos muchas islas aquí en brasil que
podríamos hacer a estas personas y
llevarlas a las islas y hacer un
seguimiento ellos no van a poder nadar
desde la isla hasta el continente es
allí donde entra la recuperación porque
estoy hablando de una isla de
segregación
eso es porque en la isla hay condiciones
para que ellos no sufran y puedan
tratarse
eduardo sostiene que la mayoría de los
sintecho en copacabana son
drogodependientes
lo que yo hago yo como carioca me siento
muy triste cuando presenció una
situación como esta tan embarazosa la
mujer se llama maria tiene 52 años y
habla español perfectamente porque su
padre era catalán está en la calle hace
8 años desde que sus hermanos la
excluyeron de la herencia a usted le
gustaría ir a una isla con un proyecto
nuevo de tratamiento
si me gustaría
porque yo conozco aquí todos los centros
de acogida todas las clínicas y ninguna
es agradable no sólo irían sino que
intentaría convencer a todo el mundo
para que vayan también
en el extremo fue se instalará una
estudiante universitaria de 23 años que
desde el inicio de la pandemia cocina
para personas sin hogar que sobrevive en
el centro del río
desde hace dos años vamos una vez por
semana a las calles para poder entregar
las raciones a veces productos de
higiene o ropa como hoy
y así intentamos poner de nuestra parte
con la comida lista comienza la aventura
para vivir una favela del cinturón
metropolitano del río de janeiro un tío
tiene que ayudarle a pasar por la
barrera colocada por los
narcotraficantes para que pueda el
taxi que la llevará hasta el centro
póngase aquí en fila por favor un atrás
del otro una hora después lara empieza a
distribuir la sopa caliente preparada
con esmero en medio de una inusitada ola
de frío
este joven llegó desde bogotá hace nueve
meses y se ha quedado en la calle acá
hay más solidarios y que un colombiano
vas a encontrar en colombia un albergue
nunca vas a encontrar
personas que lleguen así en carros a
ayudar a las demás personas
la pobreza extrema en américa latina
creció en 2021 como consecuencia de la
pandemia y ya afecta a 86 millones de
personas es un retroceso de 27 años
según datos de la onu empezamos a notar
que no sólo las personas sin hogar son
las que nos cogen la comida también hay
personas que tienen casa pero debido a
la falta de ingresos por causa del
desempleo surgido a raíz de la pandemia
o por causa del aumento del precio de
los alimentos acaban siendo obligadas a
salir a la calle para alimentarse junto
a las personas sin hogar en brasil el 82
por ciento de los sintechos son varones
dos de cada tres son negros y tienen
menos de 44 años el desempleo las drogas
o los problemas familiares los llevaron
a la calle desde 2008 el gobierno
brasileño no ha vuelto a realizar un
censo lo que impide implementar
políticas efectivas
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]